la maison relais de sainte rose a
organisé ce jeudi 15 septembre la 3e
édition du forum santé qui s'est tenue
au gymnase de la commune prévention
soins dépistage ou encore démonstrations
étaient au rendez vous des ateliers
animés par 17 partenaires alors le forum
santé en fait hein c'est la troisième
édition
qui est à notre initiative consiste à
rassembler lors d'un événement des
professionnels de la santé
de la santé du soin de la prévention et
cette année donc on a mis en place des
animations pour un public de personnes
adultes
qui es tu cap accès aux soins en fait on
essaye de faire en sorte que les
professionnels viennent à la rencontre
de ce public qui est un peu isolé en
termes de santé le point info santé du
département étaient présents sur le
forum avec pour thème l'hygiène intitulé
du forum séoul et bien moulé bien donc
c'est et porter un regard particulier
sur
l'hygiène dans la vie de tous les jours
et surtout comment on peut favoriser son
bien-être se mettre en avant justement
l'importance de l'hygiène corporelle est
dans les gènes camp pour aller seront
pas retrouvés et à côté de ça il ya
aussi cette hygiène domestique et puis à
plus large échelle les gènes
qu'environnemental donc d'un côté
tout part de soi donc les chiens de
manière assez vite
et puis les jeunes qui se diffusent de
manière collective on va dire santé va
être préservée si autour de soi on a un
intérieur qui est rangé organisé parce
que ça fait du bien au moral et en même
temps ça évite les infections les
maladies une manifestation qui a permis
de toucher les personnes isolées les
plus éloignés des structures liées aux
soins la provôté l'hygiène cobral
l'hygiène du corps et j'ai ajouté
et les mains dit
tout ce qui touche à la santé la santé
j'ai le propre de l'homme parce que j'en
la passante et on n'a rien
établissements du pôle social de la lève
pas la maison relais de sainte rose est
la première à avoir été inaugurée sur
ning elle offre actuellement 20
logements à destination d'un public
vulnérable